thanks to brilliant for keeping legal
eagle in the air get 20% off your annual
subscription by using the link in the
description the coronavirus has now
officially killed more people than SARS
and it shows no sign of stopping and
it's not clear that the US government is
actually prepared for this the
Department of Homeland Security is
falsely saying that the mortality rate
of kovat 19 is comparable to that of the
flu
worldwide I believe it's under 2 percent
what's the mortality rate for influenza
over the last say 10 years on the Mara
it's also right around that percentage
as well actually the flu is 20 times
less deadly and recently Vice President
Mike Pence was put in charge of
government's response worse there are
reports of entire cities being
quarantined in China and across the
globe but that's not America right have
you ever had a nightmare about being
permanently confined to your house can
you imagine one day waking up to find
police officers and soldiers right
outside your front door refusing to let
you leave that could never happen in
America in response to a pandemic could
it
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because the world is facing a
pandemic this is gonna be a bit more
speculative than most of the normal
videos on this channel because we're
going to explore whether the US could
legally quarantine towns cities and
states the way some other countries are
you might be surprised to learn that
there is both US precedent and law on
the subject now as of the time of this
video there are at least 80,000
confirmed cases of the corona virus
worldwide and almost 3,000 deaths
attributable to the virus and the
numbers are steadily climbing the
question is how do you stop the spread
of a disease or a virus that is
asymptomatic this is the problem facing
China and the rest of the world now
coronavirus is the name for a large
family of viruses that can cause mild or
severe illnesses and humans and animals
there are seven different strains of
corona virus known to infect humans and
before this most recent outbreak only
two of the corona viruses were known to
cause serious illness
you might recognize them MERS and SARS
so what the heck is this newest corona
virus well officially it's called 2019 -
and CoV and it hasn't been extensively
studied doctors don't know where it came
from most corona viruses are transmitted
to humans through an intermediate host
with SARS the host was palm civets for
MERS the host was identified as camels
the host for the 2019 corona virus has
not yet been identified but according to
researchers at Johns Hopkins it may have
come from bats doctors are still working
to understand the 2019 corona virus
disease symptoms course and severity
traditional flu symptoms like runny nose
sore throat and vomiting have only been
reported by about two percent of
infected patients common symptoms seem
to include shortness of breath fever and
cough but the problem with the 20-19
corona virus is that people can spread
the virus before they're even
symptomatic so far almost 80,000 cases
of corona virus have been reported in
China with about 14% classified as
severe now the first known patient
developed symptoms as early as December
although China alerted the World Health
Organization by the end of 2019 China
didn't act to quarantine or lock down
the city of Wuhan until January 23rd at
first every patients blood tests had to
be transmitted to Beijing which slowed
diagnosis and analysis and the hospitals
quickly
overwhelmed and overcrowded it appears
the Chinese government didn't want
people to panic but withholding
information is rarely a good idea in
situations like these Chinese physician
Li wen Liang and his fellow doctors
raced to warn the public of the new
corona virus in 2019 the Chinese
government immediately threatened dr.
wen Liang for spreading false rumors dr.
wen Liang has now died from the very
virus he was working to contain the
situation has caused some people to draw
analogies between the way that the
Chinese are responding to the corona
virus outbreak to the way that the
Soviet Union responded to Chernobyl when
the Soviet nuclear reactor broke down
triggering explosions fires and
radioactive smoke the Soviet government
denied the severity of the accident was
slow to release information to the
public and generally screwed up the
entire situation into a historic tragedy
so before we talk about the legality of
isolation and Quarantine Xin the United
States let's actually talk about what
that entails societies traditionally
have dealt with pandemics by isolating
people so that they can prevent the
spread of contagious disease to other
people isolation means separating people
who have a contagious disease from
people who do not quarantine takes the
isolation one step further
quarantines separates out people with
the contagious disease and restricts the
movement of people who have been exposed
to contagious diseases to see if they
get sick in either case the goal is to
stop person-to-person transmission of a
disease so what gives a government the
right to quarantine in the first place
isolation and quarantine are not just
medical terms the government has
generally speaking what's called police
power too sometimes in an emergency
legally isolate in quarantine patients
police power in this context means that
the government has a right to enforce
laws protect public welfare health and
safety if we're talking about the
federal government then many legal
scholars believe that police power is
implied in the Commerce Clause to the
Constitution and in fact by the time
that the Constitution was drafted the US
had already used quarantine powers to
deal with several public health crises
in the modern era the federal law
governing isolation quarantine is found
in Section 361 of the Public Health
Service Act this law authorizes the US
Secretary of Health and Human Services
to take measures to prevent the entry
and spread of communicable diseases into
the United States and between the states
in fact as is currently on the books
federal isolation in quarantine is
currently authorized
for a list of contagious diseases
including cholera diphtheria infectious
tuberculosis plague smallpox yellow
fever viral hemorrhagic fevers severe
acute respiratory syndrome and flu that
can cause a pandemic in order to keep
this list flexible the president has the
power to revise this list through
executive order but if quarantine and
isolation is necessary how would the
government carry out that order well
under federal law the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention or CDC
has the right to issue an isolation or a
quarantine order state and tribal
governments may issue their own orders
and ask federal authorities for help
enforcing them and if necessary the US
Customs and Border Patrol and US Coast
Guard may be asked to enforce those
orders so the question is is the US
government using isolation in quarantine
now well you may be pleased or terrified
to know that the US has actually now
issued its first quarantine order in 50
years recently health officials have
quarantined the 195 Americans who were
evacuated from Wuhan all 195 people must
remain at the March Air Reserve Base in
California during the incubation period
of 14 days 20 doctors and nurses at the
base will monitor the passengers if any
of them starts to get sick they will be
transferred to a hospital and in fact
patients in New York Los Angeles and
Chicago are being monitored for signs of
the virus and the Trump administration
recently announced it will be suspending
the entry of any foreign national who
has traveled to China over the last two
weeks unless they are immediate family
of a US citizen in addition any US
citizen who has been in China's who by
province within the last 14 days of
their return will be subject to up to 14
days of mandatory quarantine to ensure
that they are provided medical care and
health care screening according to the
DHS order air travelers without a nexus
to China may also be routed to one of
eleven airports if they discover
mid-flight that someone onboard has been
to China in the last 14 days this might
be completely necessary but the history
of isolation and quarantine in the
United States raises a lot of questions
but this is America damn it and if
there's one thing that Americans like to
do its to sue people so the question is
could you as an American sue with the
government over a quarantine order and
if you did what kind of rights do you
have to challenge what happens to you
during confinement well the answer to
that question
what kind of disease you have whether
the government is acting arbitrarily and
what era you live in so let's talk about
the legal history of isolation
quarantine in the United States the
first era of quarantine law runs from
the colonial days to the late nineteenth
century at that time infectious diseases
were a deadly serious threat to public
health so it's probably not surprising
that there are a few cases challenging
the government's broad authority to
detain and restrain individuals who were
infected or exposed to communicable
diseases in 1793 5,000 people died in
Philadelphia from yellow fever alone
Philadelphia was the nation's capital of
the time and federal officials evacuated
and left the city to deal with the
fallout so many people died that the
city lost 1/10 of its population and the
city government effectively collapsed
the quarantine order sent patients to a
hospital in the country but it wasn't
very effective since yellow fever is
spread through mosquitoes the crisis
ended finally when the weather turned
cold and killed off the mosquitoes
similarly the New York typists outbreak
of 1892 started when certain immigrants
arrived in Ellis Island many of the
passengers were sick with typhus fever
by the time the illness developed most
immigrants had already settled on the
Lower East Side in New York City the
government rounded up those immigrants
and quarantined them on North Brother
Island the incident provoked racist and
anti-semitic hysteria in the newspapers
and then there's of course the famous
eponymous typhoid mary the nickname for
a kook Mary Mallon Mary was an Irish
immigrant who carried the bacteria that
causes typhus fever Mallon was actually
immune to the disease but that didn't
stop the disease from spreading to
others and by working as a cook
Mary Mallon had spread a form of the
Salmonella disease to people all over
the city police also sent her to North
Brother Island to avoid communicating it
to other people so typhoid mary's term
of confinement was supposed to be three
years as long as she agreed never to
work as a cook however Mallon later
resumed her work as a cook and started
another outbreak in 1915 authorities
again tracked her down and sent her back
to the island for 23 more years during
this period quarantine was seen as the
ultimate public good the Supreme Court
said that involuntary quarantine was
constitutional in a case that involved
quarantine two passengers from eastern
and southern Europe on the Britannia
American and Louisiana authorities
stopped passengers from Lee
the ship despite no evidence that anyone
had the contagious disease the court
said that the government could hold the
passengers indefinitely because
immigrants were on board and of course
immigrants carry diseases not really the
courts finest moment of constitutional
analysis during this period courts
reviewed a lot of quarantine cases but
mostly they just checked to see if the
government was following its own rules
it helped that the diseases that people
were worried about were all highly
communicable like yellow fever typhus
and smallpox
moreover almost everyone living in the
eighteenth and nineteenth centuries had
lost someone to communicable disease
since there were few effective
treatments if a city like Philadelphia
could lose ten percent of its population
very quickly then communicable diseases
were seen as threats analogous to war
Americans would have to wait until the
second era of quarantine cases to
challenge the validity of involuntary
separation and quarantine in 1900
California federal court became the
first appeals court to reject a
quarantine law on racial grounds the
city of San Francisco issued an order
requiring all Chinese residents to be
vaccinated against bubonic plague the
inoculations turned out to be tainted
but the city argued that bubonic plague
was a serious problem and that Asians as
a race were more likely to carry that
disease
the California Court struck down that
law because it violated the Equal
Protection Clause it discriminated
against Asian immigrants and the city
also couldn't back up its claims that
the inoculation could stop the spread of
the diseases it was targeting of course
that didn't stop the San Francisco
health officials who tried it a second
time this time claiming that nine people
died from bubonic plague and that the
only way to contain it was by quarantine
people who lived in Asian neighborhoods
at the same time the city gave
exemptions to people who were not Asian
but lived in those neighborhoods
appropriately the angry Federal District
Court struck down this quarantine law as
well the key takeaway from these cases
is that if the government is reacting to
communicable diseases the threat had
better be real the government's action
can't just be an excuse for
discrimination in the twentieth century
though the government still found ways
to take his quarantine in isolation
powers in new directions the first
target was prostitution the idea was
that prostitutes spread sexually
transmitted diseases and should be
isolated and quarantined the medical
examinations for venereal diseases were
more invasive
personal privacy police took advantage
of this quarantine power and arrested
and detained prostitutes for reasons
unrelated to communicable diseases and
of course there was stigma towards
anyone who was quarantined for having a
venereal disease this was a monumental
shift in how public health officials
conceptualize power to stop contagious
diseases but this new relationship
between public health and criminal law
forced courts to give personal freedom a
more serious look the California courts
were the first two in the country to
establish what the government needed to
prove to detain someone who had a
communicable disease at a bare minimum
the government had to establish some
reasonable ground to believe that the
targeted person had been exposed or
infected with a contagious disease of
course at the same time people were
facing real risks from pandemics the
influenza pandemic of 1917 and 1919
killed around 50 million people it
resulted in mass quarantine orders and
bans of public gatherings and
unfortunately the isolation and
quarantine s did little to stop the
spread of disease influenza was highly
contagious with people becoming infected
after exposure of just a few minutes but
given the danger and the high death rate
no serious legal challenges seem to have
been brought during this time people
were really just trying to survive a
world war and global pandemic at the
same time so the question is can you
challenge a quarantine order today and
could you stop a quarantine in the
United States certainly modern medicine
has progressed a long way since 1917
well the answer is probably yes you can
challenge it depending on the
circumstances the Constitution says the
privilege of the writ of habeas corpus
shall not be suspended unless when in
cases of rebellion or invasion the
public safety may require it generally
this means that a person has the right
to petition the court if they are
illegally confined this procedure is
used most often to challenge a criminal
conviction but it also applies to
quarantine cases that being said it's
not often easy to win the Habeas case in
2014
Thomas Eric Duncan the first man in
America to be diagnosed with Ebola died
after Dallas hospital failed to
recognize the signs of the disease they
sent him home with a sinusitis diagnosis
and his fiance Louie Stroh experienced
the nightmare scenario I discussed at
the beginning of the video she woke up
one day to a court order and armed
guards posted outside of her apartment
TRO and her family were confined for 14
days and then sent into a Catholic
cottage for the remainder of a 21-day
order after
Duncan's death Tros apartment was
fumigated and many of her possessions
were destroyed TRO was left homeless
after several landlords denied her
rental applications trout didn't
actually challenge the order in court
but her case illustrates how restrictive
of personal freedom quarantine and
isolation can be limiting a person's
ability to travel work and to find a
place to live and it's very difficult to
overturn one of these orders you have to
show that the government is acting in an
arbitrary and capricious manner the
florida supreme court set the state
standard for reasonableness of a state
quarantine order in a 1956 case called
Moore versus Draper there the plaintiff
had challenged his quarantine for
tuberculosis the Florida Court said that
quote the constitutional guarantees of
life liberty and property of which a
person cannot be deprived without due
process of law do not limit the exercise
of the police power of the state to
preserve the public health so long as
that power is reasonably and fairly
exercised and not abused although
federal courts are not bound by the
Florida Supreme Court's decision its
statement of the law is regarded as a
general standard for determining whether
a person's due process rights were
violated the decision gives great way to
the government's determination that the
public health really is at stake and to
bring it back to the current pandemic
that we're faced with in our current
scenario this wouldn't be a hard
standard for the government to meet
coronavirus 2019 is still spreading
people are still dying in researchers
don't have a firm handle on the disease
yet though there are other issues about
how far authorities can push their
quarantine in isolation orders generally
a person in a civil confinement context
like isolation or quarantine should be
free from physical restraint but if you
were subject to isolation showing no
symptoms of infection and you tried to
leave could authorities actually
restrain you according to the supreme
court the answer is probably yes if you
are quote a dangerous patient again it's
pretty easy for the state to prove that
a person is dangerous if they are
contagious authorities only need to show
that the reason for the restraint and
confinement is not arbitrary but that's
not to say that there aren't cases where
the government has acted unreasonably
for example in 2007 the ACLU challenged
a dangerous patient determination on
behalf of Robert Daniels a quarantine
tuberculosis patient who emigrated from
Russia to Arizona Daniels had been
diagnosed with dangerous TB and when
Daniels define a court order requiring
him to wear a face mask he refused
leading to his arrest and confinement in
the Maricopa County Jail America
County Sheriff Joe Arpaio you might
remember that guy kept daniels in
solitary confinement for nearly a year
after the ACLU lawsuit the county
transferred Daniels to National Jewish
Hospital where physicians determined
that he actually didn't have dangerous
and contagious TB after which Daniels
returned to Russia
Arpaio was later convicted of criminal
contempt for ignoring a court order and
a separate matter Donald Trump then
pardoned Arpaio and they all lived
happily ever after
I stand by my pardon of Sheriff Joe and
as for whether the US government could
affect a nation or statewide quarantine
well the government has wide latitude to
isolate and quarantine anyone who has
been in the area of wuhan over the last
couple of months but for better or worse
generally the isolation and quarantine
orders can't last longer than the
incubation period of the targeted
disease the CDC currently estimates that
the incubation period is about 14 days
for the 2019 coronavirus based on
previous iterations like MERS of course
the reason governments resort to
quarantine is because the virus tends to
spread exponentially if you want to
follow in the footsteps of heroic
doctors like dr. wen Liang today's
sponsor brilliant can help you learn to
think like a scientist and get a handle
on practical math brilliant is all about
teaching you to think through math
science and computer science problems on
a deeper level all while building
stronger and universally applicable
cognitive skills along the way one of my
favorite courses is all about logic
brilliant logic courses covers liar and
truth teller riddles logical fallacies
machine logic and even some strategic
game theory logic is a crucial skill
that lawyers and even our arch-nemesis
doctors need every day brilliant lets
you learn by doing rather than listening
to hours of boring lectures learning
through doing is scientifically proven
to be the most effective way to master
any new skill and in fact I recommend
learning by doing to my law students for
just this reason are you in school right
now do you want to be a doctor or a
nurse the skills that you learn with
brilliant will help you on your way with
in brilliance library you'll find
courses and topics like calculus linear
algebra and math it applies to trading
and finance you'll also find courses on
gravitational physics astronomy and
machine learning and you can level up in
just five minutes a day by working on
the daily challenge each daily challenge
provides you with the context and
framework that you need to challenge it
so you don't have to take a deep dive if
you don't want to you can sign up and
start learning for free today at
brilliant org slash legal eagle and the
first 200 people who sign up
we'll also get 20% off their annual
subscription so just click on the link
in the description to get 20% off of
your subscription to brilliant plus
clicking on the link really helps out
this channel so do you agree with my
analysis leave your objections in the
comments and check out this playlist
over here where I explore all of the
other legal issues of the day including
other speculative legal topics so click
on this playlist and I'll see you in
court